Speaker 1: Tucker Carlson, the
well-known Fox News propagandist,
had a very sort of strange guest on
last night. And during the segment,
Tucker claimed that there were people being forced
to get fake vaccination cards. And there are a few
things about this that are ironic. See if you can
guess what some of them are going to talk about
them after we first look at the clip. Take a look.
Speaker 2: At this point, if you haven't
gotten the vaccine, which is free and readily
available, there's a reason for it. You've
thought this through and decided not to. You
thought that was your right. But people are
being forced to some are being forced to get
fake vaccine cards, which is understandable.
I think that they feel they're trapped.
Speaker 1: What do they do? So there's a
few ironic things there. Were you able to spot
them all? It's quite a few and I'm going to go
through them. So first of all, Tucker claims to be
part of the party of personal responsibility. This
is one of the the the it's a principle. I was
going to say a trope. This is one of the stated
principles of the Republican Party, personal
responsibility. But he's completely missing.
Who is actually responsible for getting a vaccine
card that is fake. It's the person who gets the
fake card. That's who's actually responsible for
that. It's not whoever whatever employer says,
hey, we've decided you've got to be vaccinated
to work here. They are not responsible for you
getting a fake vaccine card. You were responsible
party of personal responsibility, supposedly, but
blaming everybody but the person doing the actual
illegal thing. Second, no one is even really being
forced to be vaccinated, never mind to get a
fake vaccine card. And what I mean by that is,
of course, there are organizations and companies
that are now requiring employees to be vaccinated,
period. Some of them are just saying you've just
got to be vaccinated. Like the hospital systems we
talked about earlier. There are some organizations
that are saying you've got to be vaccinated
or you have to test weekly or you've got to test
daily. But in all cases, you as a free individual
in our magical country of America, with the
marketplace of this and the marketplace of that of
the job market, you can decide as an individual, I
can choose to meet the requirements of my employer
and stay working here, or I can quit and or get
fired and go find a different job. And of course,
as an individual who defends the freedom of
corporations to be unregulated and do what's
best for them, you couldn't possibly oppose that.
Right? Those are your principles now, but they
oppose it all the time. But you get to decide.
And then thirdly, and I'm guessing some of you
knew that I would eventually get to this, Tucker
works for a company with a vaccine passport system
and a stricter vaccination policy than the
one that Joe Biden announced a few weeks ago.
And Tucker hasn't complained about it once on
either of his programs, on his nighttime program,
nor on his daytime program. And as a reminder,
a few weeks ago, Joe Biden came out and said,
we are putting in place a requirement
for employers with at least 100 employees
where the employees either must be vaccinated
or they've got a test weekly. That was what
Joe Biden put in place. Fox News has a
far stricter policy, the FOX policy is
you've got to be vaccinated and submit proof of
vaccination through our vaccine passport system.
If you're not vaccinated, you have to test daily.
Remember Biden's plan? Biden's program is weekly.
Fox says we're going beyond it. We're saying
if you're not vaccinated, you need a daily test
and you need to continue wearing masks in many
settings where a vaccinated individual would not
have to wear a mask. OK, Tucker hasn't mentioned
it once. Tucker hasn't said, hey, by the way,
guys, you know, all these segments I'm doing
about how terrible all of these requirements are.
Fox's requirements, my employer has even
stricter requirements and I denounce it. He
hasn't said it once. Shocking, right, given
how principled Tucker Carlson is? Oh, no,
of course not, because it's all grift to the
degree that I would assume Tucker is vaccinated.
And I would assume that much like we'll get
to later, based on what people have said,
Tucker knows that this is a way to get good
ratings by making people angry and afraid.
So saying that someone is forced to get a fake
vaccine card because they don't want a vaccination
is like saying, I don't know, I was forced to rob
a bank because my employer doesn't pay me enough
money, really. And sadly, this perverse logic is
sometimes used to justify violent and horrible
actions. We were driven to riot because they
stole the election from Trump. We we had to do it.
Well, hold on a second. What happened to
personal responsibility? We were driven to
loot and to destroy property because they came
out and protested for better policing, which we
don't think we need. Why see how that goes? They
were forced to be criminals, and yet they claim to
believe in personal responsibility. Bottom line,
remember, Tucker is giving his audience the pablum
that they want and that is really profitable
for him. Tucker is almost certainly vaccinated.
He's almost certainly in favor of vaccines. He's
not offended enough about vaccine requirements to
even mention the fact that his employer has one
of the strictest ones. And there's a very good
article from The Washington Post called Tucker
Carlson Ties his vaccine fear mongering to a core
Republican insecurity. Philip Bump wrote this
and he tried to explain this as follows, quote.
He's enormously skilled, Tucker, at
elevating fear among his viewers,
at presenting them a sensible line of defense
against an irrational and devious world.
So he wraps the effort to vaccinate Americans into
a broad sense that America is changing in ways
that undercut its traditions. Imagine treating a
vaccine as a God, which, of course, no one does.
Fox News obviously sees value in amplifying
Republican concerns about the vaccine. If it
didn't, it's safe to assume that its programing,
including Karlsson's, would be redirected.
Fox News employees who spoke with The Daily Beast
described the network's focus on undercutting the
vaccine, or at least government advocacy of
it as, quote, great for ratings and something
that is unparalleled in getting our viewers
more excited or engaged. They are admitting
why they are doing this. Lastly, Philip Bump
writes, Fear and fury are great motivators. And
if you can make vaccination seem like part of a
government promoted effort to push Americans away
from religion, all the better. This is the game
that he's playing and he's playing it quite well.